I met him
seven years ago at a paella party
here in DC
a mutual friend like now a mutual friend
invited me and who's with a lot of my
now wife is like our like
started dating invite us to paella party
where I met where I met our next speaker
so it's very nice fortuitous night and
he's now a New Yorker so he moved up to
New York so again and I still see him
more often in DC than I see him in New
York so that's we have to fix that
um
and I was going to tell an embarrassing
story about I won't it's not
embarrassing actually all right so you
might have noticed this folks he is a
great political scientist and data
scientist yet the New York Times read an
article about him about a party he was
throwing like is it nightlife in
Presario so everyone let's let's ask him
questions about that all right
but his fun fact is that he was who
knows to stand programming language for
bayesians raise your hands proudly right
who uses it fewer people right but you
want who wants to use it everyone wants
to use it right so he was one of the
first 10 people to post on the stand
help list so he's an early adopter a
true hipster using it before it was cool
everyone please welcome David
uh hey everyone uh thanks for uh coming
to listen to this I'm going to talk
about data science and U.S politics and
you know how uh data science is used by
campaigns at least on the Democratic
side I have to admit I don't really know
what the Republicans do we don't hang
out that much but uh but uh if you know
anyone I'd love to meet them all right
so I'm just going to talk about uh so
I'm the co-founder of blue rose research
I'm going to talk a little bit about who
we are and what we do uh we are roughly
30 person firm we exclusively work with
Democratic campaigns and Progressive
groups uh you know my co-founder and I
were alumni of the 2012 Obama Campaign
uh and their analytics team which was I
think really kind of the first the first
the first campaign that I think they had
like a something like a 50-person
analytics team by the end of the
election uh so our team's an even mix
software Engineers machine learning
engineers and client-facing analysts uh
we had over a hundred clients this cycle
which included most outside groups in
the Progressive space uh and spanned uh
a lot hundreds of house races Senate
races Governor races State executive
races which includes things like
Secretary of State races and places like
Nevada or Arizona and uh also lots of
State Legislative races which were
incredibly proud of in terms of what our
shop does and I'll talk more about this
later we focus a lot on forecasting
elections helping groups allocate money
predicting uh behavior and testing
content in terms of what that entails
we've conducted literally thousands of
rcts on millions of people I think the
exact number is maybe like 14 000 pieces
of content on something like 13 to 14
million interviews um you know we
generated probabilistic forecasts for
every house senate and governor race in
the country as well as a lot of other
things and in doing this we scored
billions of rows per day and also helped
allocate hundreds of millions of dollars
in spend
um so you know how does data actually
get used in campaigns I just want to
talk through you know some of the core
questions I like to joke it's a boring
unromantic way to think about politics
which is that politics comes down to
what do you say uh where do I spend my
money and then how should well like what
what do I say what's happening and then
how should I actually spend my money and
so what what politicians say and this is
like a big part of what we do can really
take a lot of different forms you know
what policies should your basic campaign
on what AD should you put on the air
what talking points should I circulate
to the press and the reason this is hard
is that in politics if someone sees an
ad or hears a speech and changes their
mind we have no way to know that because
there are no tracking pixels in people's
brains yeah I don't know I'm sure
someone's working on it uh and so that
means in order to figure out what works
and what doesn't work you really have to
do a lots of experiments and you have to
survey a lot of people in order to
figure out what works and what doesn't
um you know prior to you know the rise
of this kind of experimentation you know
people would look at engagement like you
could just put a bunch of ads up there
and see what people click on or see what
people spend the most time on but
unfortunately the only people who engage
with Democratic content are Highly
Educated liberals and if you choose what
to tell swing voters uh on the basis of
what excites Highly Educated liberals
you might have a bad time
um so over the course you know of the
last six years you know we've built a
large-scale uh experimentation system
that's allowed us to test thousands of
pieces of content and when we've done
that we found that roughly one in five
uh advertisements that we tested made
people that be tested with the intent of
persuading people to vote for Democrats
actually made people more likely to vote
for Republicans which is bad uh and so
for a long time you know our big theory
of change was find Those ads and don't
show them to people uh and that you know
plays a big part in what we do
um another big uh another big part of
politics is just just really trying to
measure changes in public opinion which
is very hard you know public polling has
really never been super accurate but
it's really been it's been wrong and
really important systematic ways in 2016
and 2018 in 2020 also in 2022 as I think
a lot of people here were surprised
about
um uh you know at least with the
election results and 2020 was actually
so bad that it was actually the single
uh worst year for polling in something
like 40 or 50 years and if you can't
really measure what's going on then you
can't really do anything and so we've
kind of pioneered a new approach to
doing polling which involves surveying
very large numbers of people and doing
uh legitimately sophisticated
statistical modeling which I'm going to
get to in a second
um uh and you know uh so that's that's
just a big part of what we do uh in
terms of why it matters like why is it
that campaigns have to know you know
what races are close uh obviously we all
just want to know who wins but
intrinsically campaigns you know
campaign interventions are not super
effective if you show someone like a
hundred ads in the two weeks before the
election you know that will increase
their chance of voting for you by maybe
something like 0.8 percent and lots of
elections are much closer than that and
so it's very valid but it means that you
really have to concentrate your spending
in places that are close and you have to
have a good sense of the joint
probability distributions of outcomes in
order to actually get you know the best
uh get as much out of your money as you
can uh and then you know that just kind
of parlays into the next thing of how do
you actually spend your money uh which
is the campaigns uh you know spend an
enormous amount of resources I think
total spending in U.S politics is uh was
on the orders I think it's on the order
of like eight billion dollars uh and
most of that goes into TD ads and it's a
very complicated question to figure out
exactly what effects of spending across
mail and canvassing and television and
digital and across all of these
complicated media markets we'll actually
go and get you the most votes
so just to talk about why this is hard
the first thing is that politics uh is
really complicated
um you know voting behavior but
something I really like about this job
is the thing that motivates uh why
people do what they do even though
there's a lot of math is fundamentally
it's fundamentally something that comes
from sociology and history and a bunch
of other things and I'll get to some
specifics toward the end of this talk
um but basically why people vote the way
they do is really driven by a bunch of
complex factors things like ethnicity or
income or education or religion many of
which are difficult to directly measure
and many of which interact with each
other in a variety of complicated ways
how important those different factors
are uh really can vary across space and
time and uh unfortunately surveying
people is expensive uh and so it's
important to do a variety of different
kinds of pooling the other thing that
makes this really hard is that survey
takers are really really weird
um
uh this is this is I think probably the
core reason why polls are ever wrong is
that uh is basically survey non-response
bias if you look at a phone call today
only something like one in 200 people uh
pick up the phone and you know that one
in 200 person like answering a phone
survey at this point is now more
correlated with whether or not you vote
than past administrative vote history
which is which is just an absolutely
Wild Thing uh and so it's really there
used to be this world where you could
have a political science grad student
and he like Runs Out MRP on like six
variables and generates reasonable
estimates and that era is basically gone
you know at this point you really need
to survey very large numbers of people
you need to have a bunch of proprietary
third-party data and you have to do
pretty sophisticated modeling in order
to actually you know generate reasonable
estimates at least with the accuracy
that's demanded for in politics
and then the last reason why it's hard
is that uh you know our business
decisions are very sensitive to
autocorrelated error and so what I mean
by that
is you know when we fit models uh you
know our basic workflow is that we
survey uh we survey a bunch of people we
fit models and we score the voter file
and you know if there is there are
certain parts of the country my favorite
example is in 2018 there was a district
in southern West Virginia West Virginia
third where 80 of the population were
registered Democrats uh but only uh I
think Biden Joe Biden only got like 30
percent of the vote there and you know
there's like a bunch of complicated
historical reasons why that's true but
if you just fit some simple linear
models it will tell you uh you'll
overestimate vote share there by
something like 20 or 30 points and then
you both look dumb and misallocate
millions of dollars which is bad
um all right so just as I'm going to
talk a little bit uh more about how
politics has a lot of structure uh there
are a lot of deep interactions in
politics as the bayesians would like to
put it and so uh what I'm showing here
is this is uh two-way Clinton boat chair
and three-way ideology for liberal
moderate and conservative broken down by
race religiosity and education our
religiosity question here is a little
bit weird but it's relatively common in
the political science literature where
you just ask people their attitudes
toward the Bible where your options are
the Bible is a literal word of God the
inspired word of God or a book of fables
written by man uh it's a there are each
all three options are roughly equally
common and it correlates a lot better
with vote Choice than a lot of other
things like church attendance and so a
couple of I could talk about this
particular table for a really long time
but there are a couple of super
interesting things that that pop up the
first thing is if you look among white
people uh generally speaking uh being
more secular makes you uh substantially
more uh Democratic
um uh but if you look among
African-Americans obviously the range is
much more restricted but generally
speaking being more religious actually
makes you more Republican and uh sorry
uh being more secular makes you more
Republican and you know I think this
really highlights the extent to which
all of these relationships that we look
that we look at in politics are actually
historically contingent you know that
one of the big reasons why this is true
is that you know in the U.S
among you know generally uh White
churches tend to be pretty conservative
but in uh you know in places like the
South uh African-American churches play
a huge role in Democratic party
organizing and geotv and you know that's
one of the big reasons why you know we
see that reversal another example of
deep interactions I think is interesting
is that generally speaking uh being more
educated among uh you know being more
educated among white people makes you
more democratic but if you already are
very religious then actually being more
educated makes you more conservative
because it means that you follow
politics more closely and you just kind
of know uh I'm very religious I'm
supposed to be a republican uh and then
I think the other thing that's super
interesting here is really this
interplay um where you know partisanship
and ideology seem like very similar
Concepts but this really high you know
this table really highlights that they
can really diverge in a bunch of similar
ways uh sorry in a bunch of interesting
ways like partisanship is clearly not
exchangeable by race you know almost
every category among African-Americans
uh ranged between you know 94 and 97
well for white people it was between uh
15 and 75 but you know when you look at
identifying as liberal as opposed to
voting for a Democrat then actually
these two columns uh look relatively
exchangeable that being more being more
secular or having a degree doesn't
necessarily have the same relationships
on partisanship among African-Americans
as it does for white people but it does
actually have very similar uh effects
when it comes to identifying as liberal
and all that I think you know I think
you could talk about why but that this
is I think something that's really
interesting about politics is you have
all of these like uh related Concepts
that differ in important ways and your
models need to be quite complex in order
to accurately capture them
so this is a different plot this is from
2012. this is showing the uh you know
the Obama campaign's forecasting model
which me and my co-founder played a big
role in pulling in uh versus the Gallup
poll and you know one of the things to
highlight is that you know all of the uh
public opinion is usually quite stable
uh and that most public polls you know
just because they control for so few
things are much more volatile
um than uh you know than you'd expect
but the thing that's annoying
um you know is that in 20 in 2018 Barack
Obama got 52 of the two-party vote in
2016 Hillary Clinton got 51.1 percent uh
and so that was really only a 0.9 change
over four years but obviously that 0.9
percent really made a big difference and
this is one of the things that really
makes what we do very hard that you know
in our at our firm we try to measure two
things changes in public opinion over
time and also the extent to which uh
treatments and arguments change people's
minds both of these effects are very
small but it turned turns out are
actually very important so this is a
screenshot of our treatment Library
where you know we've tested where we
make available you know to a bunch of
our clients a really large battery of
different messages that we've tested and
something uh that you can see here is
that some messages really are much more
effective than other messages this is
showing the average treatment effect uh
on Senate bow Choice among non-voters
and you can see covid lockdowns forever
very unpopular if anyone runs for office
don't campaign on that
um
all right uh so just to get through some
fun technical details of how things
actually work all our production models
are Bayesian or at least approximate
Bays
um you know our traditional modeling and
our heterogeneous treatment effect
modeling um you know generally involve
millions of rows thousands of treatments
uh and also our non-experimental causal
inference it's also also Bayesian as is
our time series modeling uh but you know
unfortunately I mean Stan was mentioned
earlier here uh you know we our big
thing is that we try to fit the big
Bayesian models that people do you stand
for but we use variational inference to
try to approximate it
um it's very hard variational inference
is painful um but that's kind of what we
do and this is just showing you know our
mean mean squared error this cycle
versus 538 which just kind of goes to
show that all of this different work all
of this extra work really does make
things better but that things are still
quite hard
um so just to talk through and this is I
believe the last slide just to talk
through some challenges
um in this field you know the first
thing uh is that business school and I
suspect that this generalizes outside of
politics but I've only ever worked in
politics so I don't know
um the first thing is that
business questions from clients usually
uh are not well-defined statistical
questions uh it will be things like what
do we do about Georgia or you know uh
what candidates should we try to
nominate or uh how do we respond to this
thing that Trump just did and uh you
know most of the time that is not
something that corresponds exactly to
fitting a predictive model or doing
randomized controlled trial
um but if you focus on really
well-defined easy to measure problems
then you really end up leaving most of
you you limit your relevance and leave
most of your impact on the table
um even when things are well defined
like you have 300 million dollars and
you need to allocate them across you
know allocate that across media markets
to maximize your expected Senate seats
your answer is still realistically
probably depend on a bunch of parameters
that there is no way you can accurately
know uh or I mean you could do your best
uh and so but the most important thing
uh you know that and at least what I
found is that it's really important to
be willing to make leaps in order to
avoid decision paralysis decision
paralysis is really bad
um
uh the other thing I know you know that
I've noticed is that decision makers
usually lack background in social
science instances and statistics
um but the flip side is that they're
still usually quite smart and ignoring
them is a bad idea just to tell you know
some anecdotes about this I think back a
lot to 2012 in the 2012 campaign the
analytics team was just this incredibly
young group of people I was 28 my boss
was maybe like 23 or 24. and then there
were like these posters on the world
that were on the wall that were like
destroy the consultant save the world
because the Consultants you know they
were these older people you know who've
been working in politics for 20 years
they had been Clinton hands and you know
I hated them uh and I I just looking
back you know 10 years later I think
that probably even though they didn't
know statistics or didn't know you know
didn't know math I think like maybe like
of all the things that I disagreed with
them on I think looking back I think
they were right on maybe like 80 of the
things and that's because you know it
turns out uh wisdom is important
experience is important it's very hard
to get to the top of a high stat of an
organization it's a high status job and
ignoring what they say it's like really
easy I feel like I talk to people data
people all the time and they're just
like oh we need to have a data person in
the room you know these people just
don't get data and my experience is that
usually uh if you're saying something
like that there's something wrong with
what you're doing and you should like
analyze you should you should think
critically like I might I don't know so
uh and then the last thing I'm gonna say
is that Democratic politics
um is highly decentralized and yet you
know you have these hundreds of races
and thousands of different groups
they're all uh theoretically all trying
to do the same thing um but in my
experience uh they don't ever talk to
each other uh like you'd really be like
if you you if you can imagine two
important uh you know Democratic
politicians who you imagine have like a
weekly or monthly meeting they almost
certainly do not uh coordination is just
like a very hard problem in general and
it just means that it's really
impossible to have impact at scale and
that's you know something that we think
quite about to think quite a bit about
and all right with uh with that that's
my talk uh thank you so much for
listening uh and I'll end it there